juste à côté de l'entrée des patients la
sortie des morts la famille en deuil
regarde les travailleurs de la
croix-rouge embarquer leur père qui
était aussi un mari un frère un oncle un
ami puis il prit le corps du défunt
comme il se doit dans l'islam
la dépouille est ensuite emporté au
cimetière où elle est désinfecté une
dernière fois
puis les bénévoles transporte le défunt
jusqu'à son dernier repos en ce moment
difficile
abdulaziz supervise ces enterrements
sanitaires depuis mars
je suis un être humain si je vois une
personne qui en détresse
donc c'est
j'ai eu la piqûre de il faut dire que je
viens faire mon mieux c'est ça qui va
motiver le caser dans ça pour sauver
l'humanité
les membres de la famille regarde de
loin ils ne s'approchent qu'à la fin
quand les rameaux recouvre le sac
mortuaire
le plus jeune des fils ici c'est pour
pelleter un peu de terre sur son père
attendez à la rue la croix rouge permet
maintenant à un membre de la famille
d'assister à toutes les étapes de la
préparation du corps donc au et a eu des
rumeurs en disant que la volonté de la
creuse où les gens qui travaillent au c
est après le décès il découpa et membres
de leurs parents
donc avec ça ils ont décidé maintenant
vous faire associer la famille parce que
tout se passe devant eux
dès la fin de ses funérailles l'équipe
d'abdoul aziz est appelée ailleurs un
homme aimant dans le plus grand marché
du pays en plein centre-ville comme il
agonise et donc trois jours sur sept et
al la foule est agité le chef du
quartier en colère ils ont lu que ça ce
n'est pas un cas déboulant le médecin de
la croix rouge explique aux chefs de
quartier que le malade n'avait pas les
symptômes de l'ebola et les bénévoles
prennent tout de même toutes les
précautions nécessaires
le corps est amené au centre de
traitement des mollahs on nous
confirmera plus tard que le malade
n'avait pas le virus
il aurait donc pu être secourus mais
personne n'a osé s'approcher de lui en
guinée
des campagnes de sensibilisation ont été
lancés peu de temps après le début de
l'épidémie
cela serait en partie pour cela que la
contagion et mieux contenu ici que dans
les pays voisins mais il reste beaucoup
à faire beaucoup d'ignorance à combattre
pendant que nous sommes là à faire
comprendre la population adhère à des
jeunes de leucate et qui nous attaque
c'est tellement difficile aux morts des
fois de la pluie parce que pourquoi nous
attaquent
aujourd'hui ce que s'est passé pas peur
que cette cette maladie n'existe pas
très difficile aussi de convaincre les
guinéens d'aller se faire soigner s'ils
ont des symptômes ressemblant à l'ebola
comme la fièvre et la diarrhée et des
malaises trait commun ici les médias
mais manquent pas mais c'est un peu pour
cela pas d'équipement l'ama dick ya pas
des commandes qui qui peut les protéger
en ce qui concerne la protection
n'ai jamais peur à une malade mais si un
médecin à l'efb avoir peur de cette
maladie comme on l'est pas si eux ils
vont faire ils vont faire on les
convaincre on les dit que ja il ya le
médicament contre red bull a maintenant
ils l'ont qu'à partir à l'hôpital
très vite des scènes assez terrible
sophie vous êtes en guinée notamment
parce que vous vouliez savoir pourquoi
l'épidémie est mieux contenues dans ce
pays
est-ce que vous avez un début de réponse
oui c'est l'une des débuts de réponses
un dirigeant de médecins sans frontières
me disait cette semaine que le ministère
de la santé ici a bien des défauts mais
il a une qualité essentielle celui
d'exister
il a pris des décisions peut-être pas
toujours les bonnes mais des moyens ont
été déployés qui ont pu faire la
différence en guinée me disait cette
semaine quand on se regarde on se désole
quand on se compare on se console parce
qu'effectivement au liberia et en sierra
leone
là bas les systèmes de santé se sont
effondrés en début d'épidémie
parce qu'il n'avait jamais vraiment
réussi à se reconstruire depuis les
guerres civiles
là bas alors oui au niveau par exemple
des efforts de sensibilisation il y en a
eu mais c'est clairement insuffisant
le message ne passe pas comme une partie
du message ne passe pas et si l'épidémie
a jusqu'ici était mieux contenu en
guinée c'est clairement encore loin
d'être maîtrisée alors vous avez
maintenant passé plusieurs jours dans ce
pays qu'est ce que vous retenez surtout
sophie qu'est ce que je retiens c'est
l'insee la force de ces guinée qui sont
mobilisés qui sont au front de cette
guerre contre l'ebola qui ne sont pas
désespérer pas découragés qui ne panique
pas oui on perd c'est évident on a peur
d'être contaminés on a peur de voir ses
proches tombé malade mais la peur ne
paralyse pas elle incite les gens à
bouger à prendre des mesures
j'étais très touché de voir des mamans
être très fiers de m'expliquer comment
elles ont appris à leurs enfants à se
laver les mains tout le monde
semble vouloir faire sa part pour
réduire la contagion et éradiquer
l'épidémie c'est évident qu'ils vont
avoir besoin dead mais ils se sont pris
en main et ça c'est vraiment remarquable
merci beaucoup pour le travail que vous
faites
je vous en prie celle